monsieur la salle pour deux minutes jeu
phare de notre vie commune
j'insiste sur les 2 minutes vous avez
raison président mais je vais m'y tenir
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
navré la rue dit monsieur le président
sont dans les montagnes écoutez j'ai mis
à profit ce texte dans je note
d'ailleurs que sur l'ensemble des
colonnes de la presse je sais qu'il ne
faut pas tenir compte de ce qui s'écrit
dans la presse bien fait en relève
les questionnements que poison texte qui
pourtant a priori ne devrait pas imposer
eh bien je crois que c'est un petit peu
ce malaise
nous ressentons ne peut tout ce que
l'opinion ressort alors je vous disais
que à mon avis c'est bien grande partie
du manque d'attention que nous avons
porté à l'évolution de notre état depuis
une bonne trentaine d'années j'ai parlé
du conseil constitutionnel du conseil
d'état j'ai parlé hier soir de près
c'est de parler aujourd'hui des élus et
en particulier de partis politiques qui
me ne me paraissent pas jouer le rôle
qu'il devrait jouer par l'état dans
lesquelles nous vivre leur parler de
nous parlementaires qui sommes souvent
attaqué d'avoir toujours des votes
bloqués et je vais parler d'un problème
insidieux mais très préoccupant me
semble-t-il c'est l'espèce de nom
cloisonnement qui n'existe plus entre
hauts fonctionnaires et grands élus de
la nation
il nous semble qu'il ya trop de porosité
et ce n'est pas cette voie là monsieur
le président j'ai tenu mais si nous
semble important de dire pourquoi je
n'ai pas confiance en ce texte c'est
parce que les institutions de l'état ne
sont plus tout à fait ce qu'elle devait
être est ce qu'elles doivent redevenir
merci infiniment monsieur le président
madame semaine
mes chers collègues d'entre eux
attendent un peu interrogé sur les
raisons qui pouvaient susciter cette
espèce de gênes qui ne dit pas son nom à
propos de ce texte bien plus profonds
aux formes les matic de notre temps
qu'il n'y paraît j'ai poursuivi ma
réflexion sur la réorganisation
territoriale et sa relation
voyez-vous avec l'état je me suis dit
rendu compte que depuis 30 ans nous des
tricots qui ont systématiquement ce que
notre histoire avait mis en place depuis
clovis et que la révolution avait
remarquablement est définitivement
organisé en faisant un modèle pour le
monde entier qui n'a pas hésité à parler
de modèle universaliste
mais voyez vous aujourd'hui et ça
explique en grande partie la méfiance
compatriotes au nom et à ce que nous
faisons
plus personne ne s'y retrouve c'est la
raison je pense que lorsque nous sommes
venus il faudra revoir à la fois le rôle
de notre état je pense qu'une poirier
faire et la réorganisation mais devant
le peuple français de l'ensemble de
notre organisation territoriale qui
hélas et on va le voir avec la
disparition des communes ne ressemble
plus à la france si monsieur le député
nous